事故物件ちょっと待ってみた
茨城県のとある場所にある事故物件の方に
今回お邪魔しておりますこちら
もう外装もかなり
怪しいというか
怖いですけれども今回ここに泊まって
いこうと思うわけなんですけども今回です
ねこの事故物件なんと
案内人がいらっしゃいますよろしくお願い
します
お願いしますお願いします
よろしくお願いします
こってどういう場所なんですか
簡単に言うと事故物件なんですけどその
ここでは明確に事故が起きてました正確に
言うと事故っていうよりか実験でここで
起きてることっていうのは
殺人
監禁
息が起きている
フルセットだそれがまあ明確にここで起き
てて後とかも残っちゃってるんですよね
あとも残ってるんですか特殊
清掃がかなり甘かったんですよねまあ他に
もおかしい点はもう分かりやすくいっぱい
あるんですけど
殺人
監禁息が起きてからここが
幽霊屋敷になったのかと僕思ってたんです
けど
これ自体もあの僕所有してから全然期間
経ってないんで
わかんないことだらけなんですけどあの
最近わかったんですけど
なんかその事件が起きる前からここ
幽霊屋敷って呼ばれてたらしくて前からな
んですか前からなんですよねその時系列が
結構あやふやだったんで
わかんなかったんですけどでまあここの中
から
叫び声がするだろうまあ
窓のところに人が通ったとか通ったって
レベルじゃなくても外見て人が立ってると
っていうので
警察の方に通報が毎回行くんですよねで
警察はまあバーってくるんですけど絶対誰
もいないらしいですよその通報がもう何件
も何件も来たって警察の方本人から聞いた
んでなんでここの地元の方地元の警察の方
共通認識で
幽霊
地域さんがもう所有されてるって事なん
ですか今そうですね見つけたのが事故物件
に泊まりますみたいな
そうですちょっとあの本当に申し訳ないん
ですけどアトラクションアトラクション
イベントみたいな感じで何これと思って
ちょっと
興味本位で書かせていただいたんです
けれども一応アイアっていうイベント団体
でなるほどなるほどそこのイベント団体で
はこういう事故物件とか幽霊屋敷って呼ば
れてる場所を
購入して僕でそこに泊まれますよでクエス
トっていうのがあって苦しいのクエスト
ですよねそれをチャレンジしつつ12時間
ぐらい
滞在すると今夜の10時過ぎぐらいなので
明日の昼前ぐらいですかね
昼前ぐらい
滞在するっていうのがまあ安易やでやっ
てるイベントなんですけどイベントって
言うと結構アトラクション感が強いと思う
んですけど
そのテンション半分
お化け屋敷のやつなのかお話聞いてる感じ
カメラ回る外でもちょっとお話ししてきた
じゃないですかちょっとガチっぽいなって
思いましたそうですねここは入る前に強調
しておきたいのが契約書とかにもあったと
思うんですけど全く安全が解除されてない
ですはい
なんで他のイベントとか結構安全配慮した
上で運営してると思うんすけどここ安全
配慮してないんで
契約書には完全自己責任
最悪の
悲劇って言ったら誰か死ぬことする
ねそれが起きたとしてもまあそれはもう
自己責任となるほどという感じなんで本当
に
危険な場所です
か
場所です結構外観見ても君は悪いと思うん
ですけど中見るとここが幽霊屋敷になった
のはこれのせいなんだろうなっていうのが
すごい分かりやすくわかるんですよこんな
ことしてたら絶対ここやばいことになる
よって
わかるぐらいすごくわかりやすくやばい
ところなんで
なんか何人かでここに来られる方結構
いらっしゃるんですよね結構
複数の方がやっぱ多いです一人でも来る人
います
まあかなり仕上がってる人ですけど一人で
なんかどうなんですかちゃんと変えれて
ますみんなさん
帰れてる
なんかやっぱリタイヤする方がほとんどな
んですよ
まあ途中で帰っちゃう幽霊が出るって知っ
た上で予約しててなんで結構強い方が多い
んですけどそれでもやっぱデータしちゃう
方が多いんででそのリタイアする人数の中
で一番多いのが2人なんですよ勝手に僕
1人とか
奇数とかだと危ないっていうイメージが
あるんですけど2人なんですねやっぱ
少ないに越したこと
ないですけど何ですか今の音いやなんか
落とし聞いたことない音したけど今
本当の
[音楽]
深夜ですよ今
そうです
一人で行きたかったんですよ
余裕で2人の方がリタイヤに高いという
ことで今回スペシャルゲスト呼んでおり
ますどうぞ
俺自身が言うで
ゲゲの鬼太郎です
連れてきたので2人でちょっと一晩ここに
泊まらせてくださいはいちなみにそういう
の大丈夫まったくあれ今聞かされました
何も知らなかったですね
[音楽]
ここでリタイアさせていただきます
まだ大丈夫です
なんかお願いしますはいお願いします早速
入っていきましょう
これ中
あのー
お化け的な
危険と
何だろうな多分人間的なあれもあれですよ
ちょいちょいなんか人が
明らかに人を見たとかがあるんですよ
だからあの本当にやばい人が入ってる可能
性があるんですよね
霊的なことも人間的にもここ結構危険なん
でこれもし入った時人がいたとか例えば
なんか
バーンとかあったりしたら僕は
逃げます個人で命を
守りましょう」っていうのはちょっと強調
して僕もちょっと早く出して見えちゃう
ところ
じゃないのその時は本当にダッシュにはい
分かりました
OKです
まずは全部閉めてるんですあれ虫とか入っ
てる
これ
冗談です
ね
案内にしたから最悪だもあったけど丸ごと
外れてないですか
窓外す仕掛けはない仕掛けとかは逆に
危ないんで
しないです本当の時に逃げれなくなっ
ちゃうんで状況次第が止まれない可能性も
出てきました
止まれないっていうかもう警察案件
[笑い]
です
お化けなのか
[音楽]
廃墟ってそういうことだよね
人の仕業であることを願うばかりです入っ
ていきたいと思います
[音楽]
やばいのありますあこれは
元々あったものじゃなくて
アイアンで
呪物って言って予約付きのものを所有し
てるんですよその中で一番今まで動いた
ものがこれですね
[音楽]
ものすごい動くんで
いやーこれ怖いですか
[音楽]
監視カメラが防犯上のあれで
撮影の時は切っちゃうんですけどここと2
回2箇所にあるんでちゃんとしてた防犯
機能は一応ついてるって事ですね
入ったらマジで通報しますからやめて
くださいよここが今日皆さん
滞在する
この部屋ですねまあここの2部屋は
清掃してるんで逆に言うとあのここ以外は
一切手つけてない本当に当時のそのまま
状態なんで
割れ方とかもやだなぁ
残ってるんですけど
おばあちゃんとかです
もともと住んでた方ですね
まあこの方もうほんとこの家の情報僕
ほとんどわかんないんでほんと所有した
ばっかなんで
だから誰かわかんないです
いつ所有されたんですか
でも半年経ってないし結構最近だねだから
全然情報がまだ全然ないんですでこことか
にバーってあるのもまあこれはここの2体
の人形はちょっと
曰く付きのやつで僕が持ってきたんです
けどでしょうねこの他のやつは全部元々
あってやつですね
これ元々のやつですまあこの部屋にもう
ここら辺でも全部
何ですか
冷蔵庫です
これもねもともと挟まってたんですよ
何これ
なんか紙挟まってる今日で終わりですまだ
海が出たら来てくださいこれ元々あったん
ですかこれ元々あったやつなんで多分病気
かなんかで下手したらなくなってると
なんかこれも
歴史感じるなぁこの
鏡とかも相当古くてね
何も見えないや床が汚い
[音楽]
まあこの部屋も
またマスキング
一切触れてない状態なんですけどこの時計
はね動いてんだけど
ねこれ
昔のままですかこれもう
触れてない
なんか公共料金にいればが入ってると
なんで入間の時お腹鳴るんだごめんなさい
もうこれは不気味だっていう点が3つ
ぐらいあるんですけど
その中の一つのここで
あの
これ僕テーブルだったんで邪魔だなって
思って
かけたんですよで
避けてでこここうやって普通に歩こうとし
たらちょっと沈んでんのわかります
ちょっとじゃないですね
これもう
陥没してますよこここれ最初はもうちょい
平たかったんですけど僕が落ちちゃったん
ですよ落ちちゃったんですかここの下に
スペース
めくれるんですか
待って何これ何これ
[音楽]
これマジであったんですかこれマジであっ
たんですよでこれもなんか
[音楽]
やばいやばいやばい
リタイア大丈夫か
これ本当に何のために
魔除けのために置いてんのかそれから
またそういう呪いの類のものかちょっと
わかんないですけどおばあさんの写真だっ
たじゃんあの顔とちょっと似てるんですか
これですかだから下手したらこのデス
マスクの可能性あるっていう無くなった方
の顔忘れないためこうやって顔残して
コメントして残しているとこれ使って
大丈夫なんですありがとうございます
で
[音楽]
冒頭で言った
殺人関係
がここで起きてるんですけどその
息が起きた場所がここなんです
でしますここ
しかも
室内に井戸ある時点でちょっとおかしい
じゃないですかこれ以上ですもんねこれは
井戸です
ね
下が塞がれてるんですけど
井戸を通常塞ぐ時って完全に上まで
塞ぐんですよですけど中途半端にしただけ
埋めて上は残してるってかなり不自然なん
ですよ確かになんか
封鎖する気ないですよねする気ないですね
まあここにまあ殺害した人をここにバーン
て捨ててたらしいんですけどで
蓋をこのでかい石のこれかこれもちょっと
持ってないぐらい重たいんですけどこれを
上にドーンて乗せてまあ遺体を隠してた
らしいんですけどその息が落ちたからこの
中途半端な塞げ方をしてるのかもしれない
です入ったりすることってできるんですか
冒頭でてクエストで
闇色っていうのがあってこの中に一人で
入って
真っ暗にしてで木の板でちょっと塞いで他
の方はこの屋敷から離れるよ
完全に全部自己責任で何が起きても知ら
ないよっていう状態でやることになる
聞いた感じクエストマジでやばいですね
クエスト10個かな10個あって3つ
クリアして朝まで滞在成功したらまあ一応
クリアって呼んでてまあクリアステッカー
みたいなプレゼントしてる
感じですねそれはちょっと欲しいよ
な欲しいです
めちゃくちゃ怖いです
ここはちょっと入れないんで床が抜けて
ある
[音楽]
音がするの2体が多いんですよ
これは何ですかこれ元々なんで多分住んで
た方が来てたやつです
2人になったらどうするこの後マジで
マジで閉めないでください大丈夫だよ本当
に
[音楽]
すいません
本当だ
ハールこれ
被害者のだったら怖いなっていつも思っ
てるんですけど4本しっかりした本物の
でこれも何なのかわから
ないですね
階段塞ぐようなドアがあるんですよ
僕も初めて見たんですけど外側からしか
これ鍵かけないです
かね
閉じ込めることができちゃうっていう
構造が怖いもう
構造が結構あのものすごい
複雑なんで下手したらその大工さんとかが
自分で作った
[音楽]
かもしれない行っちゃいますか
誰か行った時にそうですね
俺の名前ははじめしゃ社長チャンネル登録
者1000万人だおい
晒されたくなければすぐ出て行け今なら
晒さねえぞ不法侵入だ
大丈夫なのか
ザ
ックいくよいないかマジで覚悟できてる
悪党がいるから
[音楽]
行きましょう
いや得意じゃないです
見えるんですか
だからこそ怖いってなりますよねだけどい
るっていうのはもう完全に分かってるんで
何何何何何何
これやばそう
ちょっと待って俺
先生降りてないもん
いや待って
最悪だ
大丈夫ですか
何この椅子
先生椅子の位置やばいっす
[音楽]
これもあの
元々なんで
来た時からこのポンって置いてあった
完全に吊るすようだな
うわぁ歴史を感じる多分子供がいたん
だろうなっていう感じなんですけど
ちょっと待って
もらったんですか
この家の
階段の下の絵とかまあ結構
絵とか見ると独特な趣味多いんですけど
多分変なもの集めの好きだったと思うん
ですよねレコードが落ちてるじゃあこれも
本当にお家にあった物ってことですか
相当ここ歴史深いと思うんでしょうね
鬼滅の刃の義勇さんの服みたいな
ちょっとなんか作業台っぽいですよね
ここはあの
キッチンが2階にもあるんでちょっとこれ
もおかしいですよね
なんか二世帯住宅っぽい
ですね今カツンと言いました
開いてたのってここじゃないですか
そういうカメラみたいな
ここが
監禁されてた部屋なんですよ
だから監禁部屋なんですよね
もともとはここにぴったりはまるぐらいの
本棚だったらしくてもう完全に出れない
状態にしてたらしいですでこの中なんです
けど
動画で
使えないと思うんですよ
結婚が結構ガッツリ残ってるんですよね
ちょっとこすってなんかDNAとかで人間
なのかなんか動物なのかをちょっと見てみ
たらちゃんと人間の血だったんでまあ
ちょっと使えないなってそれは辛いなで
匂いもちょっと刺繍がね残ってるんですよ
でここ割れてるのも内側から多分バンバン
バンバン蹴って
破って出ようとした後だと思う
はいお願いします
ちょっと匂いきついですからね
[音楽]
もう
逃げましょう
マジで
マジだすごいすごい
やばいやばい
嗅いだことない匂いから
破ろうとする感じがありますね
室内に家があるみたいな感じになってる
下手したら元々ここ外だったかもしれない
です
けど
[音楽]
階段があるんですよ
階段
どこですか
階段上まで繋がってると
ここ
登っていくと
距離が
うわーこれすごいなどんだけ
繋がってるんだ顔の何かが多いな
棚の高さおかしくないですか
めっちゃ花高いけど
[音楽]
本当だうわほんとだこれ別に先生がやった
わけではないですかこれ
[音楽]
から燃えてるんだよな
ここはもう完全に僕の敷地なんではいはい
はいまたその不法侵入して
[音楽]
貝とかあるんでほんとよくわかんないん
ですけどはい
怖いなぁ
なんてポーズしてんだよお化け屋敷系だと
思ったらマジだった楽しくバイバイ
クエストをやる予定だったのこれが先生
クエストですねそうですね
リタイアになるきっかけってだいたい物理
鑑賞なんですよ
これって
触られるなんですよね人がリタイアする
きっかけてだいたいその引っ張られた髪
引っ張られたとか引っ張られたって結構音
とかっていやいやあの動物だって自分の中
で言い訳を考えつくんですけどあの
引っ張られたさすがにもう処理できなく
なってパニックになってうわーっともう
帰っちゃうんで
それが一番起きやすくなる状況が
真っ暗にするか一人になります
この度胸試しとか
真っ暗にして一人になるんで
結局これやってる最中に物理鑑賞を着て
帰るみたいなパターンがかなり多いです
いやーでもできればステッカー欲しいよな
MacBookに入りたくね
[笑い]
これ俺たちステッカーは一応15分なん
ですけど
ちょっとねあの
精神的に
なっちゃう人がいるんですよ
だから最近は12分にしました
なんかおかしくなっちゃうんですよ
ね
なんか誰もいない時に
ものすごい声入ってて
その動画があるんですけど
警察呼ぶか
迷ったんですよ
ですけどその人間じゃなかったんですけど
[音楽]
これですかこれです
今の声ですか
追っかけてるんですよ
これ
天皇陛下みたいな
言葉が入ってて
さっき多分また見返すとわかるんですけど
天皇陛下みたいな言葉が入っててでこの
視界にこの天皇陛下の写真あるじゃない
ですか
[音楽]
下手したらここに出るで2階に出る音とか
それの音出してる方っていうのがその戦争
でなくなった系の人の可能性ありますよね
一人ずつこの持って
家の中入ってってまあ1階と2階で僕が
指定した部屋を写真で撮ってくる
と一人
それやろうぜ
でどこを写真撮ってきてもいいですか
あこれ虫か
何でした
暗転ちょっとやってみますはい
安定は僕がちょっと怖い話ししてその後
2人だったらいちいち
バラバラに
なって真っ暗にしてまあ15分間
終わったら先生が
迎えに来てくれるんですそうですね時間に
なったら
決まる時間
以外は僕は相当離れちゃうんで声で出せて
もいいんですか
そのお互い認識するような声の大きさはダ
メってことですか安定お願いします
[音楽]
幽霊屋敷まあ前回の
最後1枚写真見せるんで
遠慮しときます
聞きたく
なかったこれ絶対約束しとくんですけど僕
が仕掛けあったギミックとかあったりとか
人間キャストみたいのがいたりとか全く
ないんでなんか出たら本当にやばいんで
その時はそういう
認識で
判断してください
じゃあやりますか
大丈夫本当に大丈夫レベル
[笑い]
ですか
暗転挑戦します
ここに座ってもらう
[音楽]
ここに座ってもらいますここですここです
か
あーこれやばいわでは12分後に
座ります
先生12分後12分お願いしますね本当に
正確に計ってはいお願いします
これは精神的にきついなあじゃあ僕この
屋敷
離れるんではーいじゃあお気をつけて
ありがとうございますじゃあ門閉めとき
ますねはいそこのドアは開いてます
[音楽]
頑張ります
精神力
上げる
メディア知りたいその
床をミステリー
今落とせなかった
ちょっと待って
待って待って
本当に
きついな
結構きついな
金がなったのやばい足が止まらん
鳥肌
あいつ大丈夫かな
ビビったら負けた
精神力一番強く待って何か別のことを考え
たらいいんだよこういう時は
腹に力を入れて
金の筋トレ
なんか今風を感じた
やばいきつい
寝るか
無理無理無理無理無理無理無理無理
無理
何
何今の
嘘でしょ
なんかいるな
いるだろういるなら
やめないか俺仲良くしたいんだ頼むよ俺は
そんな悪い気がってきてるわけじゃない
大丈夫何もせず使えるから
許してくれ大丈夫か
大丈夫ですか
だいぶ
あれになっちゃってるみたいですえマジ
ですか
今どれくらい経ちました12分
良かった
大丈夫か大丈夫大丈夫
終わった終わったお疲れ
大丈夫か終わったよ
大丈夫
だった呼吸できてなかったです
クエストは1個しか無理でした無理だね
これは
僕は無理です絶対なんか仕掛けてたって
本当にみんなもう何が真実かわからない
クエスト諦めてこの後この家に
滞在して
寝ようと思いますただおっしゃってたよう
に寝るのもやばいって言ってたんで
ちょっとちゃんと寝れるのかどうかって
いうのも心配ですけどじゃあちょっと一応
寝てる時もカメラ回しておくので何かあっ
たらよろしくそれでかなり
[音楽]
音を立てた
変な音して
何
無理無理言ってるドラゴンボールGTの
ギルかお前は俺から7時まで寝れば俺たち
の歌詞ってことなはいおやすみなさい
まず寝ていいよ
[音楽]
今やばくなかった誰かいるとしか思えない
んだけどね仕込みとかじゃないんかね誰か
にさ一人待機しててだって
深夜ガチの3時とかちょっとごめん寝れる
わ
靴履いてます
よ
やらせてやってくれ
もうやばいどうしようどうしよう本当に
本当にどうしよう
ちょっと朝まで生き延びれたら
ありだ
やばい結構俺もうやばい
指示だ7時です
クリアー全く出れなかったですもう
精神が張り詰めてて
めっちゃきつかったですもうマジの寝不足
なので帰ってくる寝ようと思います深夜寝
てる時上どんどんやったじゃないですかし
ましたあれだけ本当になんか人員的なもの
じゃないかってまた疑ってるので1回上見
に行きません一応行きましょう
ここから動いてないので誰も出入りする
ことできないんですよ
誰かいますいますますよね
真上だったよね確かもう
ここら辺から多分どんどんしたんだろう
なって思うんだけどいやでもいなくね
どう考えても人がいそうな雰囲気ないんだ
よ
なあ会えるか